[Música]
a oit a todos em 2014 começa se
notificado em uma cidade do nordeste que
as pessoas estavam com um processo
alérgico e não se sabia o que era isso
estava sendo começou a ser investigado
pelo ministério da saúde em suas equipes
e não se chegava a nenhuma conclusão
já em fevereiro de 2015 já se sabia todo
o quadro clínico toda a história clínica
do que estava acontecendo
então é isso chegou até março e foi
interessante notar que eu pude observar
a um programa de televisão aqui em
salvador de grande impacto social é uma
determinada camada social que as pessoas
se queixavam da água né
então eu me pus a pensar da água como é
que eu tomo banho não sinto isso como é
que o bebo água não sinto isso esse povo
de camaçari está sofrendo com uma
legenda da água isso não é possível
então conversando com um amigo meu
médico doutor antônio carlos bandeira e
minha colega de trabalho a doutora
silvia saúde
chegamos à conclusão de que algo estava
passando então ele me ligou um dia em
março e diz assim olha tenho 150 pessoas
aqui na emergência no hospital e lá em
camaçari todo mundo se coçando com febre
é isso não é possível então todas as
histórias vez foram inventadas e pra
editar na mídia então ele me disse eu
vou coletam as amostras ea gente vai se
encontrar no aeroporto vamos dividir o
caminho você sai do canela e chega no
aeroporto então eu fui pro porto
encontrei com ele sexta feira de noite
às 20 horas e 30
eu me senti um pouco constrangido e
chegar a 2030 da noite encontraram um
outro parceiro no aeroporto e se o que
será que vão falar de mim oito e meia da
noite no aeroporto me encontrando e tal
e aí comecei a minha saga que foi pegar
essas amostras e levar o laboratório
sexta feira começa a trabalhar no sábado
domingo né
eu sou funcionário público a gente não
ganhar hora extra por trabalhar sabe
domingo mas eu tenho uma paixão que é o
meu trabalho meu trabalho pra mim é uma
das principais paixões é meu ideal de
vida o que o carrego dentro de mim você
trabalhar sábado domingo feriado de
assunto eu e minha colega em março e é
frustrante você fazer testes e mais
testes e bastante tá tudo negativo
eu disse eu não vou desistir porque se
eu desistir não me realizo esse é o meu
desafio esse é meu encontro comigo mesmo
e seguir em frente e eu comecei a seguir
em frente e no dia 28 de abril
era mais ou menos às 22 horas e 30 mais
ou menos eu estava sozinho no
laboratório e todos já tinham morrido e
eu comecei a ver os resultados positivos
do meu objetivo do nosso objetivo do meu
filho da minha colega de trabalho e do
meu outro amigo e parceiro
o médico então eu olhei s comecei
encontramos a mostra a sensação de
felicidade
eu garanto a todos vocês o dinheiro não
pode comprar que é a sensação de você
está feliz com algo que você está
descobrindo com algo que você está
encontrando com algo que você acredita
que vai beneficiar o outro ali estava a
vaidade de descobrir estava eu vou dar
uma resposta ao povo de camaçari e foi
isso que nós fizemos
demos uma resposta não foi fácil porque
depois de todos os ataques da mídia
dizendo que era falso que era isso que
era mas eu acreditava em mim e nos meus
parceiros e quando você acredita em você
mesmo você é capaz de mudar qualquer
aspecto você pode mudar aquilo que você
tem um objetivo você pode mudar sua
sociedade a sua rua seu prédio é onde
você mora em um barraco apartamento onde
você pode você pode mudar qualquer coisa
e esse foi o objetivo
e para concluir mais assim e quando eu
me dei conta que a ficha realmente caiu
como diz o mais jovem foi quando viajei
pela primeira vez agora em abril a paris
eu nunca tinha ido a paris todo mundo
falava de paris
mas eu não tinha dinheiro pra ele
terminei ainda porque uma empresa me
pagou a passagem eu fui estando em paris
eu fui um dos melhores centros de
referência do mundo que é o instituto
pasteur e de repente eu estava sentada
se como todos vocês tão citado mais ou
menos no meio tinha 600 pesquisadores
falando sobre física vírus
aí a ficha caiu e me emocionei assim uma
sensação de alegria de felicidade disse
poxa eu descobri algo que o mundo
inteiro está falando no brasil
eu descobri algo que eu contribuir para
a sociedade não me deu mais dinheiro do
que eu já tenho
eu não tenho nada vai ser o meu salário
não mudou nada continuo ganhando salário
de funcionário público
não tive aumenta porque não foi dado
aumento o governo deu mas a sensação é
algo que você não pode pagar você não
pode comprar a felicidade que você olhar
sim 600 pesquisadores melhores do mundo
está ali discutindo algo que você
descobriu e pra mim isso foi tão
importante dentro de mim que me causa
uma felicidade que você não pode
imaginar eu disse eu posso morrer aqui
morrerei feliz em paris não botar em
paris mais exportar porque paris é uma
cidade como qualquer outra que eu já
vivi eu já morei fora do brasil já morei
em buenos aires mas ali a sensação de
ver 600 pesquisadores melhores do mundo
da organização mundial da saúde dos
melhores cientistas dos estados unidos
da europa discutir um tema que eu
descobri eu não descobriu o vírus no
mundo
mas descobri camaçari descobrir aqui na
universidade federal da bahia
então com isso eu quero mostrar todos
vocês que vocês podem fazer qualquer
coisa na vida para melhor melhorar a sua
vida a forma de ser porque a gente dizer
vou mudar o mundo mude você mesmo
primeiro você quer mudar o mundo mude
você faça algo por você mesmo não
comprar um carro importado mas fazer
algo que ele traga felicidade porque o
carro é roubado
mas a felicidade que eu tenho hoje a
alegria de ver milhões de trabalhos
científicos
ser produzidos por que eu descobri
contribuir para a sociedade é algo que
você não pode imaginar então eu agradeço
até de x
eu agradeço a todos que estão aqui me
ouvindo e dizer é importante a gente
fazer algo para melhorar melhorar a
sociedade melhorar o mundo muito
obrigado a todos